cet hiver le chauffage est limité à 19
degrés dans tous les bâtiments publics
de cette petite ville de 2300 habitants
la mairie a donc acheté une polaire pour
chaque élève décision prise il y a 5
mois déjà et au mois de mai il s'est mis
à faire froid pendant la semaine où on a
arrêté le chauffage donc les enfants
sont plein d'avoir froid donc j'ai fait
remettre le chauffage en me disant que
l'hiver prochain je ferai pas comme ça
mais que je le referai des pulls des
polaires en l'occurrence pour qu'ils
aient moins froid maintenant les membres
du gouvernement vous recommande la
doudoune là c'est le dernier chic ou la
porte le sèche-lin le sèche-linge et le
col roulé non mais attendez où on est là
où on est passé
de la communication à deux balles ils
veulent pas sortir de leur bureau mais
non c'est de l'enfumage à deux balles
c'est tout simplement pour nous serrer
pour nous serrer le kiki dans les mois
qui viennent c'est de la comme à deux
balles pour nous serrer le kiki
Thierry prendrait-il son pied ou la
douleur lui fait-elle perdre son latin
c'est l'image incontournable du week-end
sur les réseaux sociaux la mannequin
Bella Adidas berger d'un matériau
liquide au défilé copernis de la Fashion
Week parisienne en 10 minutes une robe
unique était créée et des parodiesnées
voici la version mousse à raser
et sa variante un modèle fait à base de
Chantilly
incroyable bonjour je m'appelle Alex
salopez je suis dans la peau d'une
bambatomique je suis trop contente
bonjour moi c'est Elena joue les j'ai
laissé mes formes à Marseille bonjour
moi c'est jazz Dubaï je vous embrasse
très fort Kiss peace mes loulous cœur
sur vous
inquiètes pas voilà on a l'habitude on
est un pays dans lequel on a enfin pu
réintroduire le loup d'ailleurs le loup
c'est réintroduit lui-même après avoir
été massacré et éradiquer de dire
n'importe quoi il y a le loup en
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi alors tu
me laisses terminé il y a le loup en
Espagne il y a le lourd en Espagne il y
a le lourd en Italie il y a le lourd en
Allemagne partout ça se passe très bien
il y a qu'en France que ça se passe pas
bien parce que les éleveurs ne veulent
pas faire les efforts nécessaires alors
qu'ils sont largement
pour la paix dans le monde voilà j'aime
tout le monde celui qui m'aime pas c'est
pas grave je l'aime quand même le tir de
défense est autorisé il y a il y a des
tirs tu parles d'un mot que tu connais
même pas il y a des sires de régulation
il y a des tirs de régulation il y a des
tirs de régulation maintenant quand vous
regardez une femme vous avez peur de
prendre une carte dans la tête je veux
dire c'est vrai ne vous inquiétez pas
avec moi bon vous avez pas on a peur de
tout c'est-à-dire que vous regardez
c'est agréable pour un mec de regarder
une jolie femme et ben maintenant on
peut plus parce qu'on a peur d'avoir
[Musique]
voici la partie du corps suivant ok on
les appelle les foufounes
attention à ce que vous répondez
je crois non c'est pas les oreilles les
foufounes et on part chez les Bleus avec
Mario les mains c'est pas les mains les
foufounes c'est les fesses figurez-vous
ok mec Jean-Marc Généreux m'a jamais
appris ce mot là dis donc
tu as de belles foufoune c'est ta belle
fesses en fait d'accord ok très bien
on n'est pas des donc dit les choses en
fait à chaque fois je te pose la
question tu te sens bien on a une
discussion tu me dis oui ça va ben non
ça va pas en fait si ça va ah ouais je
t'ai répondu
10 % des couples font chambre à part un
couple français sur 10 fait chambre à
part un chiffre qui monte même à 1/6 si
on ajoute ceux qui souhaitent le faire
mais n'ont pas encore franchi le pas
alors on s'en fout on s'en fout pas
Didier on fout complètement Charles non
on s'en fout pas et bah alors Charles
mais parce que c'est la la promiscuité
contemporaine qui invite les gens à
s'entasser dans des lycéens de 140 cm de
large la situation elle est très très
compliquée mais moi je veux bien je mets
du mien il y a pas de souci après tu
vois quand tu me parles sur un ton comme
ça ça m'énerve un peu tu vois bah ça
m'agace moi je suis agacée
de l'amour et je peux dire que tu dors
avec les bêtes te réveiller à côté de ta
compagne le matin
sentir qu'elle est à côté de toi moi je
trouve que c'est c'est la meilleure
sensation la vie d'un amoureux voilà
c'est l'amour qui triomphe régulier du
matin
mets-toi à ma place de personne moi il
faut que je me coupe en deux pour
essayer d'apprendre à connaître l'une et
l'autre c'est pas facile je prends mais
la sortie que tu m'as fait là je vais te
dire pour la voiture
[Musique]
vous avez 63 ans depuis le 15 juillet
retraite à taux plein alors justement
j'ai tous mes points
c'est une des bonnes raisons d'arrêter
parce que tous les les
10 bonnes raisons d'arrêter voilà je dis
qu'avec le nom des missions de télé à la
con que j'ai faite j'ai même le droit à
des points de pénibilité de travail
ne vous répétez pas
sujet de le prendre pour vous